coliford lake on bodmin moore is
cornwall's largest reservoir
and in this relentless heat it is drying
up
the receding waters revealing a
landscape that has been hidden for
decades you can actually see where the
water levels were
around where the black parts are
cindy cooper runs a campsite near the
shore she is already feeling the effects
of drought during the peak of the
tourist season people come here for the
views
you normally can see out the windows to
the river
and at the moment you can't see any
water at all so it's not very nice for
them to come down and have a look when
there's nothing there to see so could
impact your business eventually yes
it could
down the road at nine stone's farm they
are trying to keep the animals cool
emma collison is worried about the
dwindling stream that supplies her with
fresh water they have only just
recovered from a tb outbreak here
and can't afford another disaster we've
come out of covid now and
and things you we thought would go back
to normal but i don't think there is a
normal anymore there's just no
you know we weren't expecting this kind
of weather and i've never known anything
like it i know i'm not that old but
it's just crazy weather conditions crazy
in some ways she's right about that
devon and cornwall have just experienced
their driest july in over a hundred
years river flows are well below normal
and reservoirs and groundwater sources
are receding and unfortunately there's
no relief in sight no forecast for
significant rainfall where it is
desperately needed
scientists say this is the new reality
of climate change and it's going to get
worse the uk will be seeing more
unprecedented events like we've had
recently
hotter drier summers more intense heat
waves more droughts with impacts on
human health
ecosystems wildfire risks and so on
a bleak picture of little comfort in
this region now being asked to conserve
water and protect this precious resource